Yeah.
And I'm in,
I'm not going to be,
because I tried,
uh,
Maria,
Juana,
we'd weed.
Yeah.
Once two years ago and I stayed hide for a 14 days straight to God man.
Did you eat it 14 days?
No,
no smoke.
He wasn't a vaporizer.
Is that yeah.
Vaporize vaporizer.
Yeah.
And I say hi for 14 days.
He says,
and I thought he doesn't write,
he doesn't,
I wasn't high.
Right?
Well probably it wasn't actually the second day,
but I thought it was like disconnected from reality will sometimes that does
happen.
And I know a story about a guy who is a straight laced guy who took some
marijuana edibles so that he could get to sleep and he had a real problem.
Like he got suicidal and freaked out and became just irrationally anxious.
He had crippling anxiety in some time for some time for weeks.
And he's a confident guy and a very handsome,
big muscular guy.
Like he just like,
you would never imagine this guy have any antianxiety.
I think some people have just the chemistry of different individuals.
I wasn't bar for death and that's what the doctor told me because I went to the
psychiatrist.
Wow.
Psychiatry,
I swear to God,
I'm that week,
that week I went to the psychiatry smell and I told him no,
I smoked that thing like 14 days ago and I still high.
And he looked at me and he gave me some,
some cycle one kicked me some bills and I was like,
oh he few stay high until tomorrow.
Take this pills.
Because what he told me something that I didn't know that it can be a trigger if
you're has some tendencies of his schizophrenia and a psychopath or he should
have,
which was not my case.
And he stole,
this is very rare,
but he can't happen,
which is not your case.
And I,
it was happy because of the setup and the next day I was okay and I felt okay
and I did and took the pills and it was crazy,
man.
Fuck crazy.
And I remember that I,
I decided to record about it cause I was like,
okay,
let me,
let me record what I'm thinking.
At least let's get some good experience out of it.
And I remember that it started to record and I said,
now I'm going to record everything that I'm thinking.
And when I look at the cell phone,
it was 45 minutes,
45 minutes of talking,
and I didn't make her realize,
I just said that I'm going to record now.
And there was 45 minutes and when I listened like 15 days after that,
I was like,
I'm so crazy.
I'm so crazy,
so crazy.
I'm gonna die.
I'm never going to understand that.
My son's talking,
oh,
is my son talking to me right now?
Wow.
That was one hit of a vapor one.
No,
he was more than one.
A bunch of hits.
He was a bunch.
Oh,
you're too tall.
You're big.
You're like a 250 pounds.
So fucking use it a lot.
Also,
they were saying,
keep hitting it because you're tall.
Because I wasn't feeling it.
Oh No.
But when I felt it,
I felt for 14 people,
that's one of the big problems with people in the first tries.
They tried too much.
That's what happened.
Yeah.
Someone just says take another hit.
It is a happy man.
I tell people viewed thinking about try marijuana going into a little bit.
That's it.
I don't feel anything.
Shut the fuck up.
Leave it alone.
It'll,
you'll eventually feel something fun for.
Yeah.
It's leave it alone,
man.
That's crazy,
That's so many people selling weeds and stuff in there.
This is not even cool anymore.
Weed's not cool.
Yeah.
It's like people are suffering.
When I do shows,
there's a lot of people talk,
oh,
I smoke this and I spoke.
That is like me,
man.
It's legal now.
Yeah.
It's just like juice.
It's not dangerous I think is good and he has to be.
There you go.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Definitely should be.
It doesn't affect me that way for me.
I've been smoking in a long time.
It's pretty easy.
I just chills me out and makes me,
it actually makes me nicer.
It makes me like a more calm person.
Makes them a more sensitive to other people's feelings.
Did you ever smoke because you fell that short intervals or like stressed out
and no,
I'm not going to perform well in this meeting or something and then was smoking?
No,
it doesn't work like that for me.
Like if I'm stressed out and I work out when you're stressed out,
that's,
that's my best for alleviating that.
Marijuana is good for me for thinking,
for contemplating and going over things and it's not,
it's not good for me for stress.
Like for what?
If I feel like tense tension,
I work out that that's what gets it out of me.